it's time for drew's news a drew's news
a day keeps the sads away and with me at
the desk he always put some pep in my
step it's rozzy rusty
it's cute
aren't we just the mauve twins i know
and then there's mauve
b arthur yeah yeah that's okay
um okay we'll get right into it first up
does everyone have that friend who loves
to cozy up in bed at night with a
terrifying murder show yes
uh-huh well a new study says that that
person is probably
a
a
lady
the daily mail reports a survey out of
australia found that women are way more
into crime shows than men 45
of women said it was their favorite
genre and social scientists have tons of
theories on this maybe it makes women
feel more prepared for what right
maybe it's a form of exposure therapy ah
yeah yeah morbid maybe it's just an
adrenaline rush whoa you get your kicks
off in a weird way
now murder shows are like the cilantro
of tv it really divides people um ross
fan or not not so much drew sorry but
right because you're not a lady well
thank you for noticing but also like
when i'm at home by myself and i'm about
to go to bed the last thing i want to
watch is no thank you i'm turning on
golden girls gem in the holograms
something else
and i have so many girlfriends who are
obsessed with crime podcasts crime shows
and then they call me when they're
scared oh my gosh i just watched the
show and i just heard a noise don't
watch it
all right i would love to get another
take on this and we have a real true
crime aficionado in our audience today
whitney whitney where are you hi
[Applause]
you're one of my girlfriends who calls
me late at night are you scared yeah
what do you watch what do you listen to
oh like all the low on orders the little
doink doing sound really gets me i'm
like okay it's gonna happen now like so
um yeah the joint joint sound i totally
know you're my favorite what do you like
about that
um i feel like i can relate just as a
human and so it kind of makes me
feel like god forbid i'm in that
situation like maybe i could talk my way
out of it or something um so that's one
of the reasons i watch it who likes to
watch like crime and murder and all of
it
because you know even people magazine
always has true crime and we get these
reports it's so fascinating about
people's watching habits and true crime
rates number one wow we are all six six
seven yeah
twisted
um you know we solved some crimes of our
own around here it's true because i got
this data i was like okay we have to do
something on the show and you know we're
not really that show that wants to like
i mean i'm fascinated by the mind of a
madman too whitney like i really am um
but you know we were like what's our
version of it so we have drew crime yeah
um and this has been a really popular
fun segment for us um we've had deborah
norville
keith morrison
um hoda hoda copy yes they've all done
it
so
tell them about the youtube well you can
catch up with drew crime on youtube.com
the drew barrymore show you can watch
the kind of fun now that's some crime i
can get into thank you very much hey
speaking of particular tastes and habits
we just learned about a real quirky way
jessica simpson she likes to eat
breakfast we have to talk about this
people report she posted a pic of her
and her daughter maxwell sharing some
bacon which i love bacon and she
admitted that when she eats bacon
she only eats
the tips
just the tip
what just the tip yeah
no no
okay
and here
don't do this to me
i do have to say the tip is always the
crispiest part right of the bacon
[Applause]
you know
i have a highly addictive personality
and i don't think i can do it i gotta go
hog here oh
[Applause]
i think i officially just pulled a rock
i am so proud of you you are such a ham
well i'm not going to finish this
because i'm so much like jessica simpson
that way
and i need to learn more from her
apparently okay we're going all the way
to glasgow scotland for our next story
the good news network reports one night
club is launching a body heat
sustainable energy technology that will
use body heat from dancers to power the
venue this is real
i know i thought this was the coolest
story they use heat pumps to capture the
heat from all the booty shakers and
twerkers and turn it into electricity
there's also a lot of this you know if
you've been all up in the club you know
that move yeah
ross i don't know about you i mean this
mama runs hot do you think that we could
power the entire studio i mean listen i
love people
[Applause]
listen i do i love people but normally
the only time i want a stranger's body
heat is in an avalanche but i am i am
willing to try it with all of you here
will you guys try it with us
all right guys we're gonna dim the
lights
tony it's all about you
all right let's do this everybody stand
up
let's stand up everybody everybody up
let's power this baby
[Applause]
wow
yeah
bye
[Applause]
you guys
our tushies turned on the light oh
[Music]
you